hi guys my name is Jess McDonald it's
the first of me today and you're
watching games but news known forth for
humor and unfailing tendency to block
everybody the pc specs for Wolfenstein
the new order were unveiled today and
it's confirming a lot of what we've
already suspected that this gen of games
is going to require a serious PC upgrade
Bethesda has said you'll need an intel
core i7 or equivalent AMD processor to
make it run fortunately the rest of the
specs aren't so demanding you'll need at
least a geforce 460 or radeon 6850 a 64
bit version of Windows 7 or 8 4
gigabytes of RAM and 50 gigabytes of
hard drive space if you'll be picking up
the ps4 or Xbox one version of
Wolfenstein you'll need 8 gigabytes of
hard drive space minimum and 47
gigabytes for a full install the ps3
version requires 17 gigabytes for the
download version and 8 for the disc
version while xbox 360 users also get to
look forward to an 8 gigabyte install
with the added pleasure of fumbling
around with four discs because that's
what it's coming on it seems that
ZeniMax are after a chunk of oculus is 2
billion dollars today after claims that
they provided VR tech to oculus
employees essentially zero max is saying
that it owns key technology used to
develop and market the rift they're
claiming that since former in software
and now oculus employee John Carmack was
performing research and development on
VR whilst under their roof as well as
being in correspondence with oculus rift
greater Palmer Luckey they provided what
they're calling necessary VR technology
and other valuable assistance to Palmer
Luckey and other oculus employees in
2012 and 2013 to make the oculus rift a
viable via product superior to other VR
market offerings oculus have called the
claim ridiculous and have pledged to
defend the company and its investors
thankfully to wind up our week a
developer has come out with a brazen
opinion for us to very agree or disagree
with creator of alice american mcgee has
that the xbox one will fail in China
when the console is released there later
this year among his reasoning is that
Chinese consumers are already accessing
consoles despite the fact that the
country had previously banned the sale
of game systems he also said that the
set-top box market is saturated by
products that are better resulting in
his comments that the move is a blunder
which will cost them dearly call Judy
2014 is officially being teased by
Activision and whether or not you're a
fan of the series i'd say burrell
somewhat interested to see if they're
gonna pull some new tricks out of the
bag this time round the game will focus
on private military contractors a teaser
video about PMC's asks in the last
twenty years global combat has seen a
steady shift towards the use of private
military corporations or PMC's what
happens when the highest bidder becomes
the world's next superpower a recently
revealed teaser site is saying you
should get ready for a new era and that
the game will be revealed on Sunday main
floor game informer have revealed the
first screenshot from the game and
digging into the source of the teaser
site reveals and extra teaser image
which seems to feature san Francisco's
Golden Gate Bridge but it's hard to
speculate what it all means just yet let
me know whether you think this premise
is a hit or a miss for call of duty and
whether or not you're keen on more of
the series that is it from me today but
remember tomorrow is top five times if
you've missed any of the good stuff from
this week it'll all be there same time
tomorrow